[Musique]
françois 1er est avant tout le premier
roi de france de la renaissance
il a laissé le souvenir d'un vaillant
guerrier et d'un grand mécène
car sous son règne on vit la france
s'épanouir sur le plan culturel françois
1er dès qu'il est roi centaines d'années
ne pense qu à l'italie les italiens
réussissent à avoir les meilleurs
peintres les meilleurs architectes l'est
les meilleurs les meilleurs sculpteurs
de la planète
et bien moi aussi je vais faire la même
chose dans le royaume de france
l'emblème de la salamandre créatures
dont la tradition dit qu'elles
prospèrent sur le feu fut associé à
françois dès son plus jeune âge et il
prouve à combien ce symbole lui
correspondait en devenant un homme qui
prospéra sous le feu des combats dans le
feu de l'amour et celui de ses
enthousiasmes passionnait françois était
un bel homme plein de charme
il possédait aussi de grandes qualités
intellectuelles s'intéressait à de
nombreux domaines
toute chose qui firent de lui un prince
d'un charisme exceptionnel en tant que
souverain il montera un grand courage
physique et prouva qu'il était un
chevalier fier et fougueuse
mais il fut un piètre politicien il
connu des succès comme conquérant et
pacificateur au début de son règne
mais le combat qui l'opposait à son
rival l'empereur charles quint occupa la
majeure partie de son règne et ne fut
guère bénéfique pour la france
le raid de françois de s'emparer de
l'italie fille de sa vie une trajet
c'est en tant que mécène et
collectionneur qu'il connut ses plus
grands succès qu'il atteigne la gloire
d'une intelligence vive et cultiver le
roi avait un amour sincère des arts et
des lettres
il attire à lui les plus grands savants
de son temps éteinte une place
importante dans l'histoire de
l'humanisme
mais c'est l'art et l'architecturé qui
furent sa plus grande passion et il
montera dans ces domaines de remarquable
capacité de discernement ce bâlois avait
un oeil pour reconnaître la beauté sa
découverte de la renaissance italienne
fit naître en lui le désir de susciter
un même renouveau de la création et de
la recherche en france sous sa
protection artiste française et italiens
se mêlèrent et donnèrent naissance à une
véritable révolution culturelle la
renaissance française
[Musique]
m
et
françois d'angoulême n'acquittent à
cognac le 12 septembre 14 100 94
il est le fils de charles d'angoulême et
de louise de savoie et appartient à la
branche de valois à angoulême de la
dynastie capétienne la maison des valois
régnant sur la france depuis treize 128
il est le petit-fils de charles 5/10
charles lesage lecomte d'angoulême son
père ne connut pas de grand succès
politique mais il hérita de son grand
père l'amour de la connaissance et
rassembla une bibliothèque de manuscrits
et d'ouvragés imprimés la mère de
françois filles du futur duc de savoie
avait été mariée à charles à l'âge de 12
ans
le couple avait eu une fille en 14 192
marguerite et deux ans plus tard naquit
leur fils on l'appela françois comme le
saint qui disait ton apparu au chevet de
louise pour lui annoncer qu'elle
donnerait naissance au prochain roi de
france
la naissance de françois eu lieu l'année
où la france dirigée par charles 8
envahi l'italie charlie 8 descend
jusqu'au royaume de naples en 494 pour
revendiquer le royaume de naples
car il est l'héritier de princes de la
famille capétienne les princes d'anjou
et donc il vient revendiquer cet
héritage puisque son père louis 11 à
récupérer la succession d anjouan 480 80
et cette première expédition des rois de
france en italie inaugure une très
longue et très longue investissements
des rois de france dans la péninsule et
inaugure aussi une rivalité avec un
souverain espagnol le roi d'aragon qui
est lui aussi directement intéressé par
la succession napolitaine et c'est le
début de ce qu'on appelle
l'investissement français dans les
guerres d'italie qui va durer plus d'un
demi siècle
l'invasion de l'italie fut un échec
charles witt s'empara de naples pour
l'art perdre aussitôt est rentré chez
lui les mains vides
françois n'avait pas trois ans quand son
père mourut en janvier 14 197 louise
âgée de 19 ans se retrouvaient veuve et
le petit prince devint le nouveau compte
d'angoulême l'année suivante en avril 14
198 le roi charles ii 8 mourut très
soudainement après avoir heurté le
linteau d'une porte alors qu'ils
revenaient d'assister à une partie de
jeu de paume au château d'amboise
il avait 27 ans
le nouveau roi louis xii n'avait pas
l'héritier des années plus tôt louis 11
l'avait forcée à se marier à sa fille
infirme jeanne de france dont le corps
déformé faisait horreur à son propre
père après l'accession au trône de louis
xii le pape a nulle à ce mariage au
motif que jeanne ne pouvait enfanter
louis pu ainsi épousé la veuve de
charles 8 and duchesse de bretagne
cette soudaine succession au trône eu un
retentissement considérable sur louise
de savoie et ses deux enfants marguerite
et françois
son défunt mari était le premier cousin
de louis xii et aurait été le suivant
prétendant au trône par le fait même son
fils qui n'avait même pas quatre ans
devenait le premier prince de sang bien
sûr la succession de françois n'était en
rien assuré louis xii était encore
capable d'engendrer un héritier
mais malgré cela louise mis toute son
énergie son intelligence et sa
détermination dans l'éducation de son
fils voyante rend sa fille qui était
destinée à être une des femmes les plus
doués de son temps une alliée dans cette
tâche
louise de savoie commencer immédiatement
à forger l'image de son fils elle
attribue à un françois l'emblème de la
salamandre la salamandre est un animal
qui est liée aux feux qui se vit dans le
feu qui supporte le feu qui sont nourris
et qui peut l'éteindre et donc la
première dimension de ce symbole c'est
que c'est un symbole d'endurance mais
par ailleurs c'est aussi un symbole
morale parce que dans la devise qui a
été retenu par françois 1er new tree
s'cauet texting our je m'en nourris et
je l'éteins le roi de france et celui
qui se nourrit du bon feu celui qu'ils
portent au bien et qui est un le mal le
mauvais feu celui des mauvaises passions
le jeune prince grandi au château
d'amboise dans la vallée de la loire
sous la protection du roi
le bon louis xii le fils du duc de
valois et lui donna un tuteur le
seigneur de bouazzi et sa mère reçu en
cadeau le château d'amboise françois
assister chaque matin à la messe dans la
chapelle saint-hubert bien qu'il ne fût
pas aussi intelligent que sa soeur et de
reçus de sa mère un respect pour les
arts et lettres en même temps qu'une
véritable curiosité intellectuelle ses
qualités devait demeurer une part
importante de son caractère
en 15 107 sa mère renforça les chances
de françois d'accéder au trône en
arrangeant son mariage avec claude fille
du roi et de la reine
il n'avait alors que 11 ans et claude
septe
la reine anne n'a depuis jamais ce
mariage elle envisageait de lui faire
contracter une union qui permettrait à
claude héritière de la bretagne
d'assurer la future indépendance de ceux
du che par rapport à la france
les valois en général n'était pas de
forte constitution
mais françois en grandissant devant un
jeune homme de haute taille musclé est
bien proportionné
doté d'un grand appétit de vivre du haut
de son mètre quatre-vingt de francs soit
dépassé d'une tête la plupart de ses
contemporains
françois 1er pour son époque quelqu'un
de très grands et il a une stature
impressionnante c'est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement vigoureux amateurs
d'exercice physique de chasse en
particulier ce qui lui vaut d'ailleurs
un certain nombre d'accidents plus ou
moins graves au cours de son existence
mais c'est quelqu'un dans le même temps
qui est présenté comme relativement
avenant c'est quelqu'un d'important mais
pas d' impressionnant et on souligne
aussi malgré son allure qui peut en
imposer on souligne son amabilité ça
sa fraîcheur par rapport aux gens qu'il
reçoit et donc en définitive il n'est
pas terrifiant canton l'approchent
en effet il était évident que le jeune
prince avait reçu une éducation
attentive
il avait de belles manières
parle est extrêmement bien et et
chevaleresque et toujours habillés de
tenues splendide et éclatante
bien que les traits de son visage ne
fussent pas ordinaire avec sa
personnalité affable il produisait un
excellente effet sur tous la reine anne
mourut et louis xii ne fut plus jamais
le même
mais cette disparition permettait à
françois d'épouser claude et illfurth
unis quatre mois plus tard le 18 mai
dans la chapelle de saint germain en
laye
louis ne désirait pas se remarier mais
il y fut obligé pour des raisons
politiques
la france avait tout perdu en italie et
les anglais s'étaient emparés de villes
françaises pour la première fois depuis
la guerre de cent ans selon les termes
du traité de paix avec l'angleterre
louis xii qui était à présent un
vieillard de 52 ans du se fiancer à la
soeur d'henri 8
âgé de 18 ans marie tudor
[Musique]
le mariage eu lieu le 9 octobre 15 114
dans son journal
louise de savoie nota qu'elle entrait en
fureur en apprenant la nouvelle
mais les craintes d angoulême ne se
matérialisait jamais louis xii appelé
aussi le père du peuple mourut sans
héritier le 1er janvier 15 115
françois lui succéda sous le nom de
françois 1er
louise de savoie écrivit dans son
journal
c'était un premier du mois de janvier
que je perdais mon époux et un premier
du mois de janvier que mon fils de vingt
roi de france les hommes qui à la cour
et est garant de la symbolique royal
pierre valoir que c'était le premier
jour de la nouvelle année le premier
mois de l'année le premier jour du mois
et le premier jour de la semaine que ce
jeune et beau prince était devenu roi
avec un prénom encore jamais porté par
un souverain de france françois 1er est
un roi qui offre plein davantage le
premier c'est qu'il est majeur au moment
où il règne a pas de régence il arrive
au pouvoir dans sa 21e année c'est à
rouen en plus ce qui est attendu qui est
attendue parce que symboliquement c'est
un nouveau roi
c'est un nouveau nom dynastique 1 c'est
françois le premier et en plus les gens
souligne qu' il a le même nom que son
peuple
françois qui est tout françois leroy
françois qui est français comme son
peuple et c'est un cycle qui est vécu
comme quelque chose de très positif à la
renaissance les rois de france sont rois
par le sang la succession dynastique est
immédiate ce n'est pas le couronnement
le sacre qui fait le roi le roi est roi
par la volonté de dieu et par la vertu
de son sang cependant il y à un
couronnement un sacre qui renforce la
légitimité du prince ce sacre se déroule
quelques mois parfois quelques semaines
après l'avènement et donc on a une
période entre l'avènement lui même et le
sacre pendant laquelle le roi est
vraiment roi mais en même temps il
apparaît encore peu publiquement il y a
une façon de faire croire que c'est le
sacre qui va révéler finalement le
nouvel événement
[Musique]
le code médiévale qui donnait droit de
pouvoir de déclarer la guerre entre est
souvent en conflit avec le serment par
lequel il avait la responsabilité
d'assurer le bien-être de son peuple
c'est à cette contradiction que se
heurte à précisément françois 1er les
princes de la renaissance menaient des
conquêtes et des guerres dans un but
d'affirmation de leur gloire personnelle
et leur gloire dynastie qu'ils avaient
le souci de s'emparer de ce qu'ils
considéraient comme des héritages n'y
avait pas vraiment de d'idées de
conquête pour atteindre des frontières
qu'on dirait naturel plus tard pour
agrandir le royaume c'était plutôt une
façon de s'affirmer dynastique mans
c'est comme ça que charles witt a voulu
s'emparer de naples c'est comme ça que
louis xii a voulu prendre la lombardie
et que françois 1er héritier de ses
droits va à son tour partir en italie à
la fin du xvème siècle l'italie se
composait de nombreux états indépendants
tous différents par leur taille leur
composition et leur mode de gouvernement
c'est une mosaïque de principauté avec
quelques très grands morceaux politique
la papauté
au centre le royaume de naples au sud
qui est détenu par des princes de la
maison d'aragon et puis plus au nord une
un ensemble pluriel à savoir que duché
de milan qui est très important la
république de venise qui est l'état le
plus riche est peut-être le plus
puissant d'italie du nord
et puis plus petit des duchés ou des
marquises à mantoue fait rare urbina
et puis la toscane florence en réalité
qui est aux mains des médicis médicis
qui vont être chassé en 1494 quand les
français mais les contemporains voyait
les guerres d'italie des années 14 190
menée par charles 8 et louis xii
les prédécesseurs de françois 1er comme
des guerres de prestige
la renaissance vie la naissance d'un
nouveau système diplomatique
inspiré des italiens le roi nomme à des
ambassadeurs auprès des cours étrangères
ce qui changeait les relations entre
cours rival françois 1er dès qu'il est
roi c'est à dire une vingtaine d'années
ne pense qu'à l'italie pourquoi parce
que ses prédécesseurs charles 8 et louis
xii avait déjà mis un pied en italie et
parce que son arrière grand mère a lui
aussi était une visconti qui avait
épousé le frère de charles ciss duc
d'orléans dont il se dit le royaume de
milan qui lui appartenait et bien
m'appartient forcément et je valais le
conquérir
comment résister à l'attrait de leader
tout au long de son enfance
les armées françaises s'y étaient
engagés dans des combats la défaite
désastreuse de 15 113 restait une
blessure vives dans la mémoire des
français
enfin l'italie était le centre de la
renaissance de la pensée et de la
création
il ne fait aucun doute que françois
voulait y participer tout le pouce est
en direction de l'italie
[Musique]
l'objectif immédiat était de reprendre
milan et de s'y établir fermement
françois dans le contexte de ses
aspirations italienne jeanjean d'abord
le climat politique et ses puissants
voisins
il eût été possible de salir à venise
puisqu'elle était en conflit avec le
saint-empire romain germanique
mais la suisse plus forte puissance
militaire d'europe et est allié aux
milanais et avait même une garnison dans
la ville elle tenait également les
principaux cols alpins
[Musique]
dès que les intentions de françois fut
reconnu une alliance ce format pour
défendre l'italie elle comprenait le duc
de milan
le pape léon 10 dont le territoire était
au centre de la péninsule
ferdinand ii roi d'espagne qui tenait
une grande partie de l'italie du sud et
l'empereur maximilien premier qui
régnait sur les territoires du
saint-empire romain germanique
cela ne dissuade a pas françois 1er de
poursuivre son objectif
il commence à planifier son expédition
militaire et l'invasion de milan porte
française de l'italie
le prologue seul de la bataille est une
des grandes épopées de l'histoire
militaire même si elle demeure parmi les
moins connus
françois confia la france aux mains de
sa mère en qui il avait toute confiance
pour diriger le pays
accompagné de sept prince de sang il
emprunte à l'itinéraire le plus
dangereux est le moins fréquenté pour
atteindre l'italie comme charlemagne
avant lui il fit franchir les alpes à
son armée des bergers et chasseur lui
ayant révélé l'existence de passe
généralement inconnu des étrangers c'est
ce qui permit aux français de déborder
les suisses qui les attendait à d'autres
cols les sommes avancées
vêtus de leurs armures un exploit
herculéen cette altitude
les artilleurs aussi relevé un défi
extraordinaire transportant à dos
d'homme leur lourd fardeau franchissant
de profonds et périlleux à 20 au plus
fort de l'épreuve françois fit à sa mère
un récit de cette folle aventure
il écrivit ce qui ne leur ont pas vu ne
croiront pas que quiconque ait pu faire
voyager les chevaux et l'artillerie
lourde
comme nous le faisons cinq jours plus
tard qui parurent sans doute cinq
siècles les français à tenir la planète
alien
ils surprennent et s'empare de la
cavalerie suisse habile à franck car
forçant le reste des troupes à se
retirer sur milan le 13 septembre
quinze mille suisse sorte pour engager
le combat avec les forces françaises
près de la ville de marignan aujourd'hui
mais les nian à 16 km au sud-est de
milan l'assaut de cette infanterie
suisse est difficilement contenue par
l'armée française le premier jour de la
bataille la bataille s'arrête avec la
nuit ou plus précisément quand la lune
ce cachot vers minuit la bataille
reprend le lendemain de nouveaux
l'assaut de la l'infanterie suisse est
contenu par l'armée elle est d'ailleurs
fait l'objet de pertes assez lourde de
la part de l'artillerie française de
rois font son premier va charger la tête
de sa gendarmerie c'est à dire de sa
cavalerie lourde et finalement c'est
l'arrivée de renforts vénitien bienvenue
dans la fin de matinée qui vont
permettre à la france alliée aux
vénitiens de faire la différence contre
cette rude infanterie suisse harnachés
de métal de la tête aux pieds
monté sur un énorme cheval de bataille
revêtu d'un tapis de velours bleu
parsemé de fleurs de lys doré et 2f
couronné le souverain était visible de
tous
[Musique]
françois avait démontré la supériorité
de l'artillerie et de la cavalerie
lourde sur l'ancienne stratégie de
phalanges des piquets et suisse il était
le nouveau maître demi
or la victoire de marignan et
spectaculaire par l'ampleur du succès
militaires mais aussi par ses
conséquences politiques et diplomatiques
les suisses qui s'étaient mis au service
de la papauté du duc de milan vont faire
la paix avec le roi de france
le pape léon 10 est extrêmement effrayée
et va accepter de rencontrer le roi de
france de passer un accord de paix la
rencontre se déroule à le mieux du monde
les deux puissances semblent
véritablement heureux de se voir
et pendant ce séjour ils échangèrent
cadeaux et promesses les on dit ce fils
du célèbre laurent de médicis amateurs
d'art comme françois 1er les dames
aiment à acquérir certaines des
premières pièces de sa collection
le pape est celui qui va autoriser le
roi de france a nommé dans son royaume
les principaux bénéficiaires ceux qui
tiennent les principaux bénéfices les
abbés et les évêques et qui va lui
faciliter les possibilités de lever des
impôts car le clergé payent des impôts
de lever des impôts sur son clergé
nationale
c'est la signature du concordat avec
concordat signé à bologne entre le roi
de france et le pape en dise il
rétablissait ainsi une égalité de
pouvoir entre la papauté et le roi
[Musique]
ceci ne blesser guerre françois 1er et
en même temps faisait très plaisir allez
on dise en france cependant beaucoup de
gens sont hostiles justement à cette
mainmise double du roi et du pape
notamment les parlementaires les gens du
parlement de paris sont très attachés à
l'indépendance de l'église de france le
parlement s'oppose à fortement à
l'ingérence du pape dans l'église
française et refusait de signer le
concordat le roi de france entrait en
fureur et menaça les législateurs
d'emprisonnement et de pire encore s'il
ne s'y résignerait pas le concordat
allait rester en vigueur en france
jusqu'à la révolution et présageait des
futurs manoeuvre politique de françois
1er pour consolider le pouvoir royal
après sa défaite à marignan maximilien
premier de habsbourg envahi en
représailles le nord de l'italie au
début de l'année 15 116 prévoyant cette
manoeuvre françois 1er s'était attaché
de nombreux cantons suisses le renfort
de 8000 soldats suisses permis au
souverain français de repousser
l'empereur romain germanique l'aura de
france âgé de 22 ans était devenu un
héros en une nuit il avait montré son
courage et ses qualités de commandant en
chef et avait réussi à étendre son
royaume en italie sa victoire éclatante
à marignan venger la défaite précédente
il avait triomphé de la puissante armée
suisse et c'était même acquis le soutien
militaire de certains cantons pour
l'avenir il avait resterez la domination
française sur milan et gênes et était
désormais en bons termes avec le pape
enfin maximilien premier n'avait pas
réussi à reprendre la main on arrive à
l'état de paix par deux aspects d'abord
par la victoire de marignan et ses
conséquences qui ont permis de signer la
paix avec les suisses et puis avec le
pape est donc de faire qu'on en italie
la situation est pacifiée et puis plus
largement par des négociations avec
l'empereur maximilien et son petit fils
charles qui est devenu le roi charles
d'espagne qui signe avec le roi de
france des accords en ce 15 116 115 110
est à la fois pour régler
les litiges italien et pour commencer à
envisager même des projets d'union des
princes chrétiens pour mener la croisade
et c'est vrai que c'est une période
exceptionnelle que ces années qu'un
117,15 119 ou les chroniqueurs le
constate la paix règne dans la
chrétienté
les toiles de françois était dans une
phase ascendante sa bonne fortune paru
complète
lorsqu'en 15 218 la reine lui donna un
premier fils le dauphin françois puis en
15/100 19 un second le futur henri 2
mais cette trêve n'allait guère duré
lancre des traités était à peine sèche
que maximilien expire à sa mort
ébranlait tout ce que françois était
parvenu à construire la place de chacun
étaient remises en question
[Musique]
à côté de ses rêves d'expansion
territoriale françois 1er passa les
premières années de son règne a
développé son pays sur le plan de la
culture
quand il monta sur le trône en 15/100 15
la peinture en france n'était pas son
plus haut niveau
l'architecturé était dominée par le
style gothique au contraire l'italie
était à l'apogée de sa renaissance après
la prise de constantinople en 453 tous
les savants tous les intellos si je puis
dire sont venus se réfugier du côté de
rome du côté de florence du côté de
bologne en emmenant avec eux toutes
leurs connaissances leurs bibliothèques
également séduire comme ça à cette
époque-là concret la bibliothèque du
vatican
et ces gens là vont être hyper protégé
par de riches mécènes qui vont leur
permettre d'accomplir leurs travaux
l'artiste ne produit pas spontanément il
produit sur commande et ses mécènes sont
évidemment pour certains et pour tous
intéressés par l'art amoureux de l'art
mais il trouve aussi dans cette activité
de mécénat une dimension qui permet
l'exaltation de leurs propres conditions
conditions de prince prince de l'église
où prince laïque ou conditions sociales
pour les élites en particulier élites
urbaines au xvème siècle
un des plus célèbres mécène de la
renaissance avait été laurent de médicis
à florence
les médicis à l'origine étaient des
banquiers et des marchands acquis le
mécénat permettait de se rendre
populaire et d'assurer leur pouvoir tout
comme son fameux grand père comme de
médicis le roi de france considérée
comme un plaisir et un devoir de se
montrer comme les médicis un protecteur
des arts
françois dit-on fut submergé par
l'émotion quand il vit à milan la cène
de léonard de vinci à son retour son
premier souci fut d'inviter le vieux
maître à s'installer en france léonard
de vinci acceptent de venir en france
bascule et j'allais dire un petit peu en
perte de vitesse en italie il ya
michel-ange qui commence à prendre le
dessus
françois avait conservé amboise comme
résidence royale il accorda à leonard
dégage pour un an le logeait au manoir
du clos lucé non loin du château et lui
donna le titre officiel de premier
peintre ingénieur et architecte du roi
là ils vont véritablement devenir des
des amis françois 1er lui rend visite
régulièrement hausse est il marche dans
le parc bras dessus bras dessous il dira
c'est un grand philosophe avec lequel il
il a eu beaucoup de plaisir à discuter
françois proclama que nul dans savez
autant que léonard de vinci
en effet son imagination était sans
limites
cet homme d'une vaste intelligence
s'intéressait à la géologie la botanique
l'anatomie et à l'invention pure de
nombreux modèles de machines qui seront
construites plus tard ont été retrouvés
dans ses carnets de notes
parmi ceux-ci on compte un véhicule
blindé un gilet de sauvetage
un parachute un sous marin une
pelleteuse mécanique des portes des
cluses un véhicule à ressort et une
machine volante
léonard de vinci construisent
illégalement des machineries pour les
fêtes de la cour que le roi avait
plaisir à organiser la du monde
le vieux sage mourut trois ans après son
arrivée à amboise à l'âge de 67 ans bon
de là à dire comme la légende le voeu
que léonard est mort vraiment dans les
bras du roi c'est un peu excessif mais
il était vraiment très proches l'un de
l'autre
françois va irriter acquérir certaines
des oeuvres les plus célèbres au monde
la joconde joyaux de sa collection a
longtemps été le tableau le plus
apprécié du musée du louvre
léonard l'avait rapporté avec lui
d'italie
leroy aimait particulièrement les
peintres florentin il employait des
émissaires qui rassemblait des oeuvres
pour lui le meilleur d'entre eux étaient
sans doute un italien du nom de giovanni
battista puccini c'est par son entremise
qu une pietà du jeune maître de florence
andrea del sarto ainsi qu une madone
furent envoyés à françois en 15/100 16
par la suite en 15/100 18
andrea del sarto fut invité à venir
peindre à la cour il accepta pour un
séjour de courte durée censés payer les
factures de son épouse outrageusement
dépensière les cadeaux diplomatiques des
papes et des princes permis aussi
d'agrandir la collection royale le pape
léon 10 était le protecteur d'un
contemporain de del sarto le peintre
florentin raphaël avec michel-ange et
vinci ils forment la trinité
emblématique des grands maîtres de cette
époque il faut leur adjoindre bien sûr
le sublime peintre vénitien titien
françois 1er va être aussi peint par
titien mais il n'a jamais obtenu que le
titien viennent en france faire ce
portrait titien à pain françois 1er à
partir d'une médaille depuis venise
françois ne négliger aucune piste
michel-ange fut lui aussi invité à la
cour de france mais il refusa on trouve
d'ailleurs rarement de ses oeuvres hors
d'italie
plus tard dans son règne françois 1er
emploi ya des artistes italiens de façon
plus constante
on pense par exemple aux primatice tous
ces gens qui viennent de bologne de
florence le primatice rosso lou cap et
demi tous ces gens là vont venir en
france
à l'exemple de léonard et suivre les
conseils du roi françois 1er pour
peindre à fontainebleau wire le peintre
de la cour jean cloud et qui combinées
des techniques flamande et italienne
créée à une école du portrait
d'inspiration purement française
françois premier montera un grand
discernement en protégeant cet artiste
majeur
pétrarque poète et érudits du 14e siècle
et appelé le père de l'humanisme
mouvement philosophique qui a permis
l'épanouissement intellectuel de la
renaissance
il est le premier à avoir lancé l'idée
d'une renaissance de la littérature et
de l'étude classique de la grèce et de
la rome antique les humanistes attachait
une grande importance à la dignité aux
relations et aux capacités humaines
il pensait que la réussite sociale
n'excluait pas forcément une relation
authentique avec dieu puisque celui ci a
donné aux humains leur potentiel
intellectuel et créatif pour qu'ils
l'utilisent pleinement françois 1er a
été élevé dans le beau si je puis dire
dans dans l'élégance avec une maman qui
était très érudite avec une grande soeur
marguerite de navarre de valloire qui
était elle aussi très érudite qui était
poète d'ailleurs et il a été bercé dans
ce monde là si bien que il bondit sur ce
qu'on appelle l'humanisme c'est à dire
l'humanisme qui est quelque chose de
merveilleux jusqu alors on était encore
dans le moyen-age c'est à dire pas dans
l'obscurantisme mais presque on
craignait la mort on ne voyait que dieu
on ne vivait que pour dieu dans l'iss
maintenant avec avec l'humanisme
on va vivre pour l'homme on va vivre
pour le bo pour la qualité pour la
culture françois 1er de par son
éducation est intéressé par les
questions que nous appellerions
intellectuelle les questions que soulève
l'humanisme
cependant ce n'est pas lui même un
intellectuel du tout le mot est
anachronique c'est quelqu'un qui a une
honnête formation mais il suppose un
excellent latinistes en revanche il est
très sensible
là encore à la conversation qu'il peut
avoir la conversation les traits qu'il
peut avoir accès humaniste il en reçoit
régulièrement il discute avec eux et on
a une image célèbre ou qui représente
l'un de ces humanistes en train de faire
la lecture non seulement au roi mais à
ses enfants et aux principaux
personnages aux principaux dignitaires
de sa cour le poète le plus doué de la
cour était clément marot
il réintégra les sources classiques dans
la poésie française
et c'est ainsi que s'épanouir de
nouveaux genres et m mais c'est écrit
comme ceux de nombreux humaniste lui
valurent des difficultés avec les
autorités religieuses
parmi les nombreuses figures littéraires
du règne de françois 1er le plus
talentueux de tous fut sans doute
françois rabelais il est tenu pour l'un
des plus grand génie comique de la
littérature universelle rabelais était
un docte et rudy tout autant qu'un
auteur de satire histoire grotesque de
jeux de mots et de chansons paillardes
ses oeuvres majeures eurent le droit de
circuler car elle bénéficiait de la
protection royale
l'entourage du roi comprenait plusieurs
humaniste en particulier son secrétaire
et notaires guillaume budé
c'est lui qui persuada le roi de francs
des reins collège consacrée à l'étude
des langues classiques françois envoya
le directeur du collège du pape à rome
et d'autres émissaires lui chercher des
manuscrits et des livres rares comme il
l'avait fait en matière d'art
ces efforts permirent de créer une des
plus belles collections de manuscrits
grecs d'europe occidentale bien qu'il ne
lui est jamais accorder le soutien
financier promis au départ un collège
classique le futur collège de france fut
fondée par françois 1er en 15 129
[Musique]
françois fille son chemin parmi des gens
qui pensaient qu'il était possible
d'envisager différents points de vue
sont pour autant se détourner des
enseignements essentiels de dieu et du
christ c'est pourtant cela qui conduisit
les humanistes au conflit avec l'église
les relations entre l'église la papauté
et le monde des savants le monde des
humanistes qui redécouvre la littérature
ancienne qui ont le souci de revenir aux
sources de la culture classique et
chrétiennes sont complexes
elles ne sont pas radicalement opposés
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de prêts là il
ya beaucoup de théologiens qui sont
eux-mêmes au fond des humanistes y ont
le souci de retrouver la vérité des
textes c'est le cas d'erasme erasme
c'est un homme d'église et c'est aussi
le prince des humanistes comme on l'a
surnommé puisque il a composé en latin
des commentaires religieux des oeuvres
moral des oeuvres théologique c'est le
cas de lutter lutter c'est un homme
d'église
donc il n'y a pas d'opposition ces deux
l'église justement que né l'humanisme en
grande partie la plupart des humanistes
à l'origine sont des gens d'église
cependant il y a des choses que l'église
ne va pas accepter elle ne va pas
accepter la remise en cause d'un certain
nombre de fondement de des croyances
traditionnelles leurs écrits critiques
alimentaire un mouvement qui se répandit
sous le nom de réforme
une autre découverte importante de
l'époque
l'imprimerie permis à un grand nombre de
gens de se procurer des livres et ils
purent désormais lire la bible dans leur
propre langue
les abus de pouvoir du pape sur l'autre
est un sel qui alluma lincendie des
revendications de la réforme au début
sous l' influence de sa soeur bien aimé
françois se montra assez tolérants
envers ce nouveau courant il le
considérait utile d'un point de vue
politique car elle conduisait de
nombreux princes germanique à se
retourner contre son ennemi
charles quint françois et marguerite
s'était lié d'amitié avec un petit
cercles influents de réformateurs
modérés
en plusieurs occasions leroy usa de son
autorité pour sauver certains d'entre
eux qui accusé d'hérésie était promis à
une mort imminente
françois dû faire face à d'énormes
pressions
on exigeait de lui qu'il adopte une
position orthodoxe contre la diffusion
du luthéranisme en france il montera
d'abord de la résistance à l'idée de
persécuter ses propres sujets le
parlement concentre à tous ses efforts
pour éradiquer l'hérésie durant
l'absence du roi
plus tard dans son règne françois
changer d'attitude
quand la question de la nouvelle
religion et de la façon de traiter les
hérétiques comme on nommait les
protestants se transforma en un combat
politique et morale qu'il perdit à la
fin du compte
[Musique]
françois avait une passion pour les
beaux-arts mais il aimait aussi
construire tout simplement
il était profondément impressionné par
les merveilleux bâtiment renaissance qui
l'avait vu en italie en particulier les
palais de milan et venise
pour ses premières entreprises
architectural il se concentra dans la
vallée de la loire à amboise sa maison
d'enfance à blois la demeure de claude
et à chambord au coeur de la forêt de
blois amboise demeurera la principale
résidence royale au cours des trois
premières années de son règne
louis xii y avait déjà fait construire
une seconde elle perpendiculaire à celle
de charles ou 8 dans le style
renaissance mais le premier bâtiment sur
lequel le roi exerça sa passion pour
l'architecturé fut le château de blois
que l'on pourrait appeler le versailles
de la renaissance les modèles qui sont à
l'origine des châteaux de la loire sont
plurielles tout d'abord il ya une
dimension qui vient de l' architecture
française traditionnelle
quand on regarde un château moderne du
temps comme le château de chambord on
s'aperçoit qu'il a quatre tours des murs
un donjon comme des constructions
anciennes et puis évidemment ce qui
inspire aussi françois 1er
c'est l'héritage italien pensons par
exemple à blois à olot djia qui donne
qui donnait à l'époque sur de vastes
jardins
maintenant qu'ils donnent sur
l'extérieur du château c'est loggia sont
directement inspirés de loggias qui ont
été construites dans les états du pape à
rome où palais du vatican même plus
précisément belvédère et françois 1er à
cette tradition française
cette influence italienne et il va
vouloir faire des choses nouvelles
exceptionnel sans équivalent en europe
il y arrive par exemple avec le célèbre
escalier à double révolution de chambord
et il y arrivera aussi un petit peu plus
tard avec la galerie françois 1er de
fontaine
l'ancienne forteresse féodale des
comptes de blois de 20 résidences
royales lorsque louis xii s'y installa
au début de son règne
claude defrance sa fille et les pousses
de françois avait grandi dans ce château
et y était très attaché elle le choisit
donc pour élever ses propres enfants
sous françois 1er l' influence classique
c'est ça d'être uniquement décoratives
et commença à marquer la structure un
magnifique escalier a été ajoutée à la
façade et capte toute l'attention
[Musique]
trois de ces faces sont encastrées dans
le mur il reprend la tradition française
de l'escalier extérieur en spirale les
roms extérieurs sont couvertes de
sculptures délicate face à des escaliers
sont animés par la multiplication des
emblèmes royaux salamandre couronné de
françois 1er et monogrammes f&c du roi
et de la reine blois et en la demeure de
la reine
c'est là qu'elle avait désiré vivre avec
ses enfants il est donc pas surprenant
que françois est voulu se bâtir une
demeure entièrement à son goût c'est
avec chambord qu il y parvint cet
édifice énorme et somptueux du bâti ex
nihilo
neil de blois n'était pas terminée que
le roi travaillait déjà sur ce château
qui allait devenir le phare de la
nouvelle architecture à la française
doit être un merveilleux château dans
lequel ces enfants vont passer une
grande partie de leur enfance
amboise également et puis un jour en
partant à la chasse
parce que c'est un chasseur impénitent
le cher françois 1er eh bien ils
découvrent une anciennes fortifications
médiévales pas très loin de la loi et il
se dit mais c'est intéressant d'autant
que tout à côté
j'ai une amie une amie très tendre qui
vit tout à côté
madame de toury qui était de la famille
de rohan qui était une de ses maîtresses
et s'est dit si je me construis un
château ici je ne serai pas très loin de
maîtresses bon la liaison avec même de
toury ne va pas durer suffisamment
longtemps parce que le château a quand
même coûté 220 mille tonnes de pierres
et puis a duré plus de la construction a
duré plus de trente ans naturellement on
pense que vinci avait dessiné des plans
pour cet édifice
chambord était un immense projet conçu
pour ressembler à une gigantesque
forteresse royale
il consiste en un donjon carré flanqué
de tourner massive aux quatre points
cardinaux le plan des pièces adoptent le
modèle d'une croix grecque qui s'étend à
travers les douves et divise le tout en
quatre blocs
[Musique]
un escalier à double hélice permet
d'accéder au toit ou plus exactement à
une terrasse qui fait le tour du donjon
et permettent une vue parfaite sur les
multiples cheminée tourelles dentelées
et clocheton qui ornent les toits de
chambord avec plus de 200 pièces c'est
le plus grand château de la vallée de la
loire
[Musique]
à la mort de maximilien premier en 15
119 le trône du saint-empire romain
germanique se retrouva vacant son petit
fils charles était son successeur tout
désigné
mais il fallait pourtant qu'il fut élu
par les sept prince électeur de façon
surprenante
françois se porta candidats et envoya au
delà des alpes
des émissaires chargés de promettre aux
électeurs argent et faveur en échange de
leur vote pour le roi de france
finalement charles parvint à racheter
plus d'alliés que françois et il devint
l'empereur charles quint
en définitive les princes allemands vont
préférer la tradition habsburg même si
on reproche à charles de patte du tout
un prince allemand un charme c'est
quelqu'un qui est né à gand c'est un
belge si j'ose dire qu'ils roi d'espagne
mais bref ils vont préférer cette
tradition habsburg plutôt que
l'originalité exceptionnelle qui serait
celle d'un d'une élection française
le roi de france en apprenant la
nouvelle dit je remercie dieu de m'avoir
épargné les responsabilités de cette
fonction est parti ensuite à la chasse
charles quint gouvernait ta présence sur
le saint-empire romain germanique une
réunion de territoire pour la plupart
allemands et italiens
il y as en europe quelques grandes
puissances
il y à l'empereur il y à halle une
monarchie qui est en train de se
reconstruire en espagne où le loup
charles quint va aller régné pendant
plusieurs années il ya le roi de france
qui a un prestige considérable depuis sa
victoire de marignan et son accord avec
le pape
il y a enfin le roi d'angleterre henry 8
henri vide qui est un prince ambitieux
qui est à la tête d'un état encore
faible sur le plan diplomatique et
militaire mais qui al'intention
peut-être de remettre le pied sur le
continent
la france est le nouvel état des
habsbourgs semblait être sur un pied
d'égalité
si bien que le rôle de l'angleterre
devenait primordial une alliance avec
elle assurait la domination mais sa
neutralité était en théorie un gage de
paix
l'angleterre se retrouva donc courtisés
à de nombreuses reprises par les deux
grandes puissances
l'exemple le plus connu de ces
tractations et l'entrevue du camp du
drap d'or
[Musique]
du 7 au 24 juin 15 120 le camp du drap
d'or fut le lieu d'une rencontre entre
les roi henri viii d'angleterre et
françois 1er il fut établi dans une
vaste plaine des flandres entre les
châteaux d'ardres et de guînes dont le
premier à partenaires la france est le
second en angleterre la rencontre devait
resserrer les liens d'amitié entre les
deux rois et françois espérait bien
gagner à sa cause le roi d'angleterre au
détriment du saint-empire chacun des
rois tenta d'éblouir l'autre à grand
renfort de pavillons somptueux de
vêtements couverts de pierreries de fait
éblouissante de musique de joutes et de
jeu les tentes et les costumes briller
tant les tissus est en fait de soie et
de fils d'or que le site fut appelée
camp du drap d'or
mais malgré cette pompe ces effusions et
les échanges de cadeaux
on ne parvint à aucun accord personne ne
se doutait qu'un peu plus tard dans
l'année
charles quint à les déclarer la guerre à
la france et que le versatile roi
d'angleterre serait à ses côtés
aussitôt élu charles quint déclara que
son élection mettrait fin au traité avec
la france
ce fut le coup d'envoi d'une rivalité
qui se prolongera durant toute leur vie
françois cerné de tous côtés se senti
menacé à juste titre c'était la
perspective de perdre l'italie qu'il
affectait le plus car il était une idée
largement répandue selon laquelle
contrôle et l'italie était la clé de la
domination sur l'europe les événements
préludant à l'éclatement de la guerre
furent en partie provoquée par la
stratégie de françois 1er
il avait décidé de détourner charles
quint de l'italie en menant au cours du
printemps 15 121 son désir de conquête
vers le royaume de navarre dont il
s'estimait un héritier légitime et vers
le luxembourg à l'été de la même année
mais le pape léon disent trahis françois
1er et se tourna vers l'empereur la
mainmise des français sur milan et est
désormais remise en cause
les guerres d'italie reprirent temps 15
121 quand les armées impériales espagnol
est celle de la papauté lancé une
offensive sur milan et brise rc défense
[Musique]
le maréchal français le vicomte de
lautrec se retira pour l'hiver et le
printemps venu
il tenta avec des renforts suisse
d'assiéger milan et pavie sans succès
les français se retirèrent à nouveau
afin de rassembler leurs forces
l'armée impériale germanique suivi leurs
traces et s'installe après d'un lieu-dit
bicoque d'où le nom de big up ne se
sentant pas de taille à mener une
attaque frontale lautrec entrepris de
couper les lignes de communications
ennemies mais les mercenaires suisses
n'ayant pas perçu leurs soldes exiger un
affrontement immédiat une terrible
défaite pour les français et les
mercenaires suisses qui sont à leurs
côtés depuis marignan les suisses
combattent aux côtés des français et les
mercenaires suisses qui n'ont pas changé
leur façon de combattre il chargea
l'apic frontalement se font décimé une
nouvelle fois finalement mais cette fois
il s'agit de l'artillerie et des
arquebusiers espagnol et impériaux qui
les massacres au cours de la bataille de
la bicoque 3000 suisses dont 22
capitaine trouvèrent la mort
les survivants s'enfuir vers leurs
patins sans les mercenaires dont ils
avaient besoin
lautrec n'était pas en mesure de garder
le contrôle de la lombardie les
territoires qui étaient aux mains des
français tombèrent un à un dans celle de
l'armée impériale et les troupes
restantes se retirèrent en franchissant
de nouveau les alpes
après la chute de milan 15 122 la
situation continue à empirer
la défaite de la france poussent à
l'angleterre à entrer en guerre aux
côtés du saint-empire romain germanique
henry 8 voulaient s'emparer de la
couronne de france charles quint
réclamait la bourgogne la champagne le
dauphiné la provence et le languedoc
le royaume était menacée de disparaître
en plus d'avoir perdu un puissant allié
françois devait faire face à des
troubles à l'intérieur même du pays
dans ces années qu'un 123 424 la grande
crise est liée jeu précisément à la
succession de bourbon les bourbon qui
sont des branches la famille royale
possède un territoire considérable dans
le centre du royaume et la dernière
duchesse suzanne de bourbon meurt en
15/100 21 elle est mariée à son cousin
qui est un bourbon d'une branche cadette
charles de bourbon que françois 1er a
fait son connétable son chef de guerre
en 15/100 15 mai la succession de
bourbon est réclamée par la mère de
françois 1er louise de savoie qui est
une cousine germaine de la défunte c'est
une histoire un petit peu compliqué bref
ce soit un cousin et une cousine qui
s'affrontent pour la succession et les
autorités françaises vont de le procès
va donner la victoire à louise de savoie
charles de bourbon le connétable juge
qu'il a fait l'objet d'un déni de
justice de la part de son suzerain
françois 1er et il va se tourner vers
son autre suzerain qui possède aussi
pour sous lequel il possède aussi des
terres comme vassal sept autres suzerain
c'est charles le charles quint au
service duquel il va se mettre pendant
toute la fin de son existence
et pour achever le tout le sang lui
réserva dimanche chagrin personnel
la reine claude épuisé par ces
grossesses tomba malade et mourut le 26
juillet à l'âge de 24 ans elle avait
donné à françois 7 merveilleux enfants
puis en septembre leur fille charlotte
âgée de 8 ans mourrut de la rougeole
l'étoile du roi de france paraissait se
ternir elles étaient 15 124 henry 8
charles quint et charles de bourbon qui
avait retourné sa veste et vivait à
présent en exil en franche comté étaient
alliés mais leurs tentatives commune
pour envahir la france demeurèrent sans
succès ses ennemis s'étant repliés
françois pu enfin reprendre son projet
longtemps différées d'envahir l'italie
ils étaient impatients de répéter son
exploit de marignan ses conseillers le
lui des conseillères et le prêt sert
d'attendre le printemps le 17 octobre
louise repris la régence et françois
franchi les alpes pour la seconde fois
françois 1er et prouva de sérieux revers
après les succès militaires et
diplomatiques qu'il avait connu au début
de son règne dans les années 15 120 il
semblait que son étoile avait été
remplacé au zénith parcelle de son
nouveau rival charles quint qui se
révélait un adversaire de taille
en dépit de ces avanies françois resta
ferme dans sa détermination de remettre
le pied en italie il franchi de nouveau
les alpes avec son armée et une fois sur
le sol italien se prépare à affronter
les forces impériales cette guerre
contre charles quint à l'état lui
permettre de conquérir des territoires
et d'assurer sa gloire son rêve de
gouverner l'italie
allait-il se réaliser ou l'histoire s'en
souviendra d'elle comme d'une folie bien
que françois et jusque là échoué dans le
projet d'étendre son royaume
ce prince de la renaissance avait prouvé
son talent de protecteur des arts et des
lettres et avait largement contribué au
développement culturel de son pays
en dix ans seulement il avait par ses
efforts et son soutien financier
contribué à donner naissance à un
nouveau style pictural et architectural
l'urgence de la guerre le distrayait
parfois de son engagement auprès des
érudits mais il ne cessa jamais de leur
accorder sa faveur royal malgrè les
oeuvres splendide qu'il avait acquise sa
bibliothèque qui s'était
considérablement enrichie et ses
splendides réalisations architecturales
de blois et de chambord les premières
années de son règne ne furent pas les
plus fertiles la renaissance arrivait à
la fin d'une première étape le
maniérisme été dominant les idées
françaises et italiennes continuer à
exister côte à côte
elle devait maintenant fusionnée au
cours des années qui suivirent france
quoi continue à attirer de grands
artistes de son époque avec qui il
collabora pour que s'épanouissent une
véritable renaissance française
[Musique]